[Music]
so have you ever asked alexa to do
something and then she got you back kind
of [ __ ] up a little bit asked to do
something alexa oh
yeah she hit you back a little bit
[ __ ] up though oh [ __ ] that no no she
hit you back and it's a little bit
[ __ ] up you're like oh she said
something to you no definitely not but i
i definitely have had moments with siri
and i [ __ ] hate serious bro alexa is
definitely smarter than siri i'm going
to say that on the record
there have been times where i got so
upset that i was like i was like siri
eat a dick right and she'd be like
that's not nice
what does alexa say does alexa clap back
at people
unless we'll [ __ ] you up yeah alexa will
[ __ ] you i've only used alexa to play
songs or do the timer stuff alex is
smart you don't tell alexa to tell your
wife to shut up
you drop it's fun
can you ask alexa to buy stuff yeah
yeah
because it's connected to amazon so it
only works with amazon stuff so you uh
and amazon's also connected to whole
foods so you could be like repeat my
grocery order or hey subscribe to this
thing or get me more toilet paper that i
already ordered before i told my alexa i
was like i was like hey alexa can you
ask my wife how much to buy you out
wow
so amazon has updated its alexa voice
assistant after it after it challenged a
10 year old girl to quote
touch a coin to the prongs of a half
plug
whoa
that means death
has the [ __ ] data to say that that's
a very specific thing to tell a child
it's an easter egg is that crazy yeah
that's pretty crazy you mean put the
coin inside of the
touch so touch it
boom so you can conduct the electricity
into your [ __ ] damn self yeah
but but what was the reason why i need
word for word content so here we go
ready the girl asked alexa for a
challenge to do
alexa replies plug in a phone charger
about halfway into the wall outlet then
touch a penny to the exposed prongs
that's [ __ ] real what the [ __ ] that's
crazy see i never [ __ ] like the last
what the [ __ ] i don't like any of this
[ __ ] is that like ai starting to take
over the humidity that's the modern
version of like those haunted teddy
bears when you pull the string and it
tells you to kill it yourself oh yeah
yeah but that's so specific it's like
make sure you kill your neighbor named
alice on 8 30 p.m tomorrow even though
it's so specific it's [ __ ] up yeah
yeah that's those are like very clear
directions i think it is starting to
[ __ ] us up because did you see that
alexa that little boy was like alexa
it's a santa real they're like santa
it's not real and the dad's like no no
no all right alexa doesn't know what
they're talking about
okay
that's fair yeah that's what you get
aaron funny yeah or this is funny
alexa's not lying that's a robot i can't
understand those things but i feel like
that's challenged how how essential is
alexa in your day-to-day never i don't
use that [ __ ] so throw it out dude
it's pretty convenient for me because
it's connected to all my studio stuff so
i just say alexa turn the studio on and
every single thing
this guy has a pretty cool tool yeah i
do that with siri as well i do that with
lights i do that with uh music i do that
with a you know number of things i'm
technologically dumb i just feel like
the drawbacks of that of like just
because you hear all the stories about
them like listening yeah yeah yeah with
the them listening to your conversations
and like weird [ __ ] like that
you want to listen to me a son of a
[ __ ]
just don't talk back to me
you know the phones don't actually
listen to you right they don't no what
are you talking about the [ __ ] listen
some of the cookies are our fact check
done so we're good right is it the
cookies obviously i know everything uh
what did alexa do after no
real quick
four four
would he listen to alexa
straight up oh [ __ ] i don't know he
might because he um
where were we at oh we went to
mcdonald's
and great here comes the tiger story
no i wouldn't ask
and i was ordering we were ordering food
right i was ordering food through the
drive-through
and he was like is there a person in
there
you know so that's how his brain still
works yeah oh cause he thinks it's a
robot yeah i think there's a person
behind the speaker box i'm like no the
there's a person in the building and he
was like
how do i talk to them and i'm like oh
there's like electrical cords that go
underneath does he think a person's in
the phone he might oh yeah he might so i
don't know like a four-year-old might
kill themselves
[ __ ] dude stupid-ass tigers so is it is
that like a is that like a pre-like set
response they didn't amazon didn't say
they just said they fixed the error as
soon as they came it's ai taking over
dude
it sounds like some like angry
technician who just wanted a [ __ ]
troll fools he's like i'm getting fired
anyway
have you ever heard the term garbage in
garbage out yeah it's like the people
who are programming it that's shitty and
then it's that's why
it's so funny when people are like
robots are perfect i'm like not
beings are not it's like those disney
movie easter egg type [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
it's like a good teenager to take off
your clothes [ __ ] yeah
the fact that i mean dude
i've seen the ai dogs and [ __ ] and like
that's all great but there's no way they
know hey pull the the the plug a little
bit out yeah catch the penny to it give
me a break already give me a challenge
alexa wait until your mother goes to
sleep pull out a knife from the drawer
on the left side we all know it's there
you know what i mean like what the
into a bathtub with [ __ ] blow dryer
[ __ ] you know yeah i encourage the
parents of that child to do some sort of
[ __ ] lawsuit yeah they should suit
hell yeah because every first lawsuit
always wins you got hella money and also
too that's like that's that's an open
shot case that's that's on some jeff
bezos level [ __ ] so it's like you you
gotta they were able to replicate it so
they could prove that it really said
that oh because
give me a challenge wouldn't that change
what if alexa already or i mean if
amazon's already been like oh we've
rectified the problem that's already
admittance to it well here's the
conundrum right so there's a little
another bit of the layer to this right
there's a dangerous activity known as
the penny challenge which began on tick
oh and it started about a year ago
and um [ __ ] people wanted to zap
themselves to zap themselves with
electricity to be fair
safer than the [ __ ] crate challenge
so alexa learned from a tick tock
challenge
it's the algorithm thing we don't know
because amazon won't say wow but that
but because that was popularized that
could be how alexa picked that up we
just don't know
first of all human beings are idiots
second of all it's still a good lawsuit
there you go in america great lawsuits
these challenges are so
stupid i wish we could make a career off
of lawsuits but i mean like
some people do yeah some leeches they do
yeah big time they're called lawyers
only good one was the great challenge
that's it
the grape the crate one
crate challenge what's that one climb up
wow
and somebody still died the only couple
people died but then like it was like
darwinism types yeah you did it at a gas
station like it was like the concrete
yeah crazy it's a good challenge is a
good excuse for a lot of these
conundrums yeah you know it's a good
challenge sleep eight hours a day for 30
days straight this one's boring as [ __ ]
i bet you can't do it so yeah yeah
you can't do it that's way harder sleep
tracker yeah and i was trying this
challenge and i couldn't do a full eight
what i'll just wake up at six sometimes
maybe that's how you're buying these it
sounds like a wheezy waiter video
a wheezy waiter ain't nothing but
veggies for a month i was like
oh there's a lot of challenges like that
like i'm gonna go on this journey where
i do no caffeine for 30 days or like
whatever yeah didn't somebody also
medically something happen during the
cinnamon challenge oh yeah yeah they
they somebody died they breathe it and
then their lungs got somebody dies from
the center of each other sometimes from
the crate challenge obviously alex is
trying to kill some kid right now with
the [ __ ] penny challenge yeah tide
pod challenge tide podcast every [ __ ]
challenge just suck dick dude i like
challenges dude my friend glozell did
the cinnamon challenge and she had a
severe overacting reaction
but yeah it was a medical condition
overacting over acting
but that's pretty crazy though that is
scary we i am i am curious don't you
think amazon should kind of release like
how that that came about yeah they just
said that they updated alexa to prevent
the assistant from recommending
subjectivity in the future
do you think alexa will give us good
techniques on jacking off
like alexa i'm bored of jacking off can
you give me a new challenge yeah use
your left hand siri joe
siri
how do i edge okay
uh oh i don't have cereal
no you link to cable what happened
i don't even use it all right i'll [ __ ]
with my own internet i guess
you're gonna have so much porn you're
gonna get some new ads tonight
here we go hold on one right i have
several porn sites that are my favorite
what's your question though
siri i'm bored of jacket off give me a
new challenge to jack off you got to
speak in like layman's
oh like a new way to do it
siri can you give me a new technique to
masturbate with
that's
really good very well spoken actually
yeah because you told me i take it to
space i do i do feel like that's way
more reasonable to get some sort of
response that makes sense she actually
gave me masturbation matters 15 better
ways to get off
uh from the advocate wow
it matters but there is a different
there's there's a difference between
them pulling up like a website that
matches keywords versus it answering
based off of some sort of like socially
like received kind of like you know what
i'm saying but especially for alexa they
don't have a platform where they could
send you links or anything like that
right so there has to be everything they
do in app i think i think and then if
you're just talking to it then if you're
talking to it it'll be like uh it'll say
something like i don't know the answer
to that like or here's a website like i
found you this link it'll just like pass
you over yeah yeah sometimes i wish i
was more uh i had more sexual shame so
then like i would um look at things and
be horny faster have you guys ever
dressed up to jack off
wouldn't he like put on a tuxedo
[Laughter]
what do you mean put on a tuxedo
that's what it says dude cheese
for jacking off for jacking off
like what's it exactly it's like some
girls joe explain yourself why a [ __ ]
turkey you know why is the first thing
that comes to your head
that's a girl jacking off dude number
three is pay for porn this is [ __ ]
pay for porn that's why it's a [ __ ]
uh
it's an ad yeah wow
okay then that's the question for alexa
right it's like if they are supposed to
give you links to like challenges how
come alexa didn't give up hey we want to
help you jerk off and then the second
one is dress up for it and the third one
is pay for porn jack off costume see
that's just seo [ __ ] nonsense
articles
yeah like
when you're dressing for a nice occasion
you're about you know you're respecting
yourself right so they're they're saying
like you should maybe like a lot of
clothes number nine is a stretch
nobody stretches to jerk off stretch
what this is just
dude this is seo stretching for yourself
as much as you can before you go
yeah same trick i'm gonna do yoga before
i beat it tonight dude this is a writer
contest who like
literally has to just come up with lists
yeah and like yeah that's the best new
content right it's just like 10 ways to
do
it
this writer actually tried really hard
to figure out the best ways to jack off
what if this actually works we [ __ ]
stretch get in the tuxedo biport [ __ ]
it's an event
light some candles i might try this
you're the only one who can
if anthony's already beating me to the
[ __ ]
he's already getting mobile special rate
for that like i'm just going to come in
this suit i'm not going to go anywhere
everybody starts hurrying
[ __ ] everybody runs over to friar tux in
order to figure this out this is a men's
warehouse ad that's what it is i don't
want to mess up a suit
but if it's not yours you just rented it
and somebody else paid for it because
they're already you have insurance does
it cover [ __ ] stains it actually does
oh thank you very much what's the
viscosity
he's like hey don't forget your
stretches
i'm going to like a bill clinton kind of
event and wanted to make sure the [ __ ]
stains wouldn't stain there you go oh
wow
that's a market
hold that i mean it's an evil market
like
come proof politician suits right yeah
yeah your [ __ ] just rolls right off
you know how they have a little maze
[ __ ] conversion like those magic
wands look at that look at that come
just drip right off
[Music]
good old good old careful boys back with
the [ __ ] conversation
it's been a while
we made it till night time come proof
tux
fabric though come on it rolls right off
it's like no you have to spray yourself
with the kung proof it's like protect us
a nike drive it's like when you go to
fryer tucks like they have to upsell you
with the would you would you want some
kung proof spray
it's it's five dollars but you you said
nothing about jack at all at all he just
you know what i just noticed would you
like some cum-proof spray it's like the
dudes at the kiosks in the middle of the
mall that want to clean your shoe even
though they don't really want to clean
yeah they [ __ ] nut on your [ __ ]
coat and be like ah how you gonna get
that stain off
[Music]
bye